so to start I would love just one word
from each of you to describe your
experience or that you would attribute
to your experience rather and then tell
me why you chose that word how about
thrilling um I picked that word because
I love this show it's a very dark and
Theatrical sort of um am I in a movie
kind of vibe so it was very thrilling
for me to be a part of a production and
a show
that had so many theatrical elements to
it where you know big brother is it's
you're on a set and it never changes you
don't really go outside the colors are
always the same whereas this show I love
the ambience of the castle I love the
fashion everything about it was
thrilling to me what about you Dan I
feel like I see some things yeah I I
mean I would say very uh the word would
be appreciative I'm appreciative that I
got the opportunity to play this game
even more appreciative that I got to to
play as a Trader uh because that just
you know that Lit me up I I was so
excited and then I also hope um you know
that people who enjoy the show whether
you know or they they're fans of like
Janelle or big brother or whatever
reality TV show that hope that fans
appreciate um you know how hard we
played this game and in particular on my
end I tried to set up scenarios that
people would enjoy watching and be like
okay like this is what I expected to see
from Dan and even something like pi
parvy like to me as a fan that's what I
would want to see and as a fan of parvy
I'm like yeah of course I want to play
with you even though you know it may be
a little dangerous I tried to do things
that would make a great show um and just
because I really appreciated being a
part of the whole thing absolutely and I
did I will say when we were doing that
interview in Scotland I felt it I felt
it I was we all talked about it after we
were like he's probably a traitor right
that was I loved watching y'all play the
game during the interviews
MJ what about you twisty um
unpredictable
because it was just
so so many different directions and so
many people to read constantly you had
to be a player and an
observer and
um I just thought that you know one of
the I was one of the people that went
into it saying like Lara and Marcus are
a couple like that's never going to work
and then you know watching the way
everything unfolded was just so
fascinating and to be in it it was like
the experience of a lifetime beautiful
so would you have done anything
different uh yeah I probably would have
watched all of the other uh Traders and
I would have tried to watch Big Brother
and Challenge and um Survivor I'm aware
of like how that is because I just know
I don't have that in me but strategy is
just something that I don't um I don't
operate that way so I could probably
learn a thing or two in that department
all right I like that more research it's
sounding like what about you Janelle go
ahead I would have really like to calm
myself down and I really would have
liked to play more dumb I would
have loved to just not well not play
basically just be really bad at the game
and just be like I don't know what I'm
doing I
I think MJ is a traitor you guys even
though I know she's a faithful I wish um
I would have played really dumbed it
down because playing as a faithful as
you know um you know if you are a Trader
hunter or someone that has a really good
read on people or um have any sort of
influence on anyone you will be targeted
um so maybe dumbing it down quite a bit
I like that I like that um so for all of
you I my last question would be would
you and it kind of ties into what I just
asked but what would be your number one
advice for future players of the game I
think as a as someone coming from a
completely different realm right this is
a brand new game or it's it's second
season in the US I would say and it's
hard until you're there but to realize
how quickly the game moves yeah and how
many different variables are at play at
any given time and the fact that there
really isn't it it felt like as you play
this the game there isn't a lot of
carryover from day to day it's like
every day is a new day and kind of work
that you put in on the day before you're
like okay that's not as relevant you
know the next day as it was on the day
that you that you were trying to do work
um so I'd say it's just very fast-paced
and um the sooner you can pick that up
the I think the better someone would do
in a game like this advice would be to
make
sure that you're ready to go go home but
you're like mentally not going to you
know completely
self-destruct um but talk to
everybody
and you know like Dan and Janelle were
just saying saying like they did not
form an alliance or let anybody know or
let it look like they were so I think
that's really smart because people are
watching you at all times yeah I would
say my advice to play a good faithful
game which I think a faithful game is
really freaking hard I would have loved
to play a Trader game I would say get
the people that you it doesn't really
matter to get a Trader out day one two
three four whatever get people that you
trust that you can really really
actually trust and vote the people out
that you just don't trust so who cares
if they're a faithful if they're not
they're going to try and vote you out
anyway just vote them out don't take
anything personal just vote those other
faithfuls out because it's a numbers
game you really don't have to I mean if
you're looking at the long-term game how
it moves you really don't have to get a
Trader out until like mid game so you
know just get the faithfuls out there
are to cause you personal problems or
cause your game damage should we do a
seminar should we sell tickets to a
seminar I mean I'd buy a
ticket I couldn't do it I'm not a
reality star but I'd still buy a ticket
we will yeah for sure it'll be fun it's
fun I love it and I love that take um
Janelle thank you for sharing that thank
you all for sharing um everything with
me I really appreciate the opportunity
to talk to you again and I know people
are excited to see your
game than thank you
too